qui sera son 1000e il ya des cadeaux il
ya des qu'elle ne boit pas après 99 1999
on dirait la ferai ma faute a rencontré
une meuf c'est très long de l'amérique à
90,9 1999
tu touches patrick survivre
[Musique]
vous les gars
cent mille soixante abonnés c'est juste
complètement ouf parce que j'ai commencé
l'année au 1er janvier j'ai publié une
vidéo
mes bonnes résolutions dans cette vidéo
des voies de résolution j'en faisais un
peu d'introspection de l'année 2017 et
puis je vous disais vraiment les
objectifs que j'ai fixé le cap pour fin
2018 à ce moment là j'étais à quelque
chose comme 13000 abonnés treize mille
et quelques et des brouettes et je
m'étais dit fin d'année au 31 janvier
à la fin de l'année 2018 ma bonne
résolution mon objectif c'est qu'on ait
atteint les 100 mille abonnés alors ça
peut paraître un peu dingue comme ça
parce qu'effectivement 100000 ça se fait
pas en un claquement de doigts il faut
beaucoup de temps mais très clairement à
cent mille abonnés au 31 décembre 2018
on pourra dire que le pari est gagné 99
1900 aimez vous êtes vraiment des geeks
ça sert à quoi d'avoir des potes sont
sur leur smartphone tout le temps comme
toi genre alléchant van toor ghar vous
voulez ça là j'ai un petit tir à vous
seul alsacienne cuvée réserve travaux va
pas ça ne va pas fort du même juge le
pompon champagne c'est ouf
tu travailles j'te juin déjà sacré je
peux prendre ton champagne je rachèterai
une bouteille à 300 milles
tu vas gausser de l'angle ans à la place
de ton champagne là bas autant prendre
le bus
bon c'est quoi qui m'a franchement allez
les gars sortent et les coupes
si vous parlez stats si vous montrez des
chiffres un petit peu sur mon ordi dans
quelques instants
c'est juste démentiel c'est une vraiment
hyper heureux parce que vous savez ça
fait partie des rendez-vous qu'on a et
c'est aujourd'hui que cette vidéo c'est
parce que vous êtes là parce que ce que
je vous propose comme contenu vous plaît
et bonbons la cgppa faire la pleureuse
ses diplômes mais c'est vrai que c'est
assez c'est vrai que c'est assez dingue
parce que les gens se rend pas trop
compte
je comprends c'est vachement compliqué
parce que vous pouvez pas forcément vous
rendre compte de l'autre côté du travail
que c'est du travail que c'est de
publier une vidéo par jour sept jours
sur sept
et ça pendant un an alors effectivement
il ya des jours où j'ai pas publié deux
vidéos ou tout simplement parce que je
ne pouvais pas notamment quand je suis
parti à vegas en début d'année j'ai
trouvé un derby qu'il avait pas
d'internet c'est un petit peu compliqué
dans les demeures la collection était
pas terrible dans les hôtels est un peu
dure donc du coup et j'ai perdu quelques
jours donc ça arrive quelques fois il ya
eu quelques vidéos qui ont tout pété
cette année que j'ai pas pu faire mes
rendez vous compte là on est le 28
novembre 2018 est ce qui est
complètement dingue c'est que moi je
suis né le 28 novembre 1979
ça veut dire que le jour de mon
anniversaire le jour de mes 39 ans je
passe par le cap des cent mille abonnés
et en plus qui est vachement drôle c'est
que c'est un 28 novembre que j'ai
rencontré ma compagne il ya pile poil
dix ans en 2008 ces notes fois là c'est
un peu une journée un peu particulière
où tout se mélange tous regroupe tout ça
pour donner un espèce de résultats un
peu fou pas j'avais dit les gars que je
bosse et où la prenne au sérieux
on est les gâteaux le champagne est au
frais les copains sont là on vous attend
la soif du 1er janvier jusqu'à
aujourd'hui en 11 mois en même pas un
mois
vous avez été 87000 à vous abonner à la
chaîne c'est juste complètement dingue
si j'en crois les productions de ce choc
blade début 2019 le 8 janvier 2019
on sera en tout cent vingt-cinq mille
c'est dingue
[ __ ] ouvre le champagne ne rouvre le
jamais
je prépare le matériel interdiction
d'ouvrir un cadre sans l'ouvrir et la
demande et goût là il reste encore cinq
personnes on va y arriver on voit que
j'espère qu'on en soit là les vrais
tubes ray et c'est beau ça ça claque ça
anti char c'est vrai break tant
qu'artiste c'est juste hilti bleu clair
mais qu'est ce que je vais donc vous
montrer un petit peu les stats on était
à plus d'un million du début d'année
là on est à 12 millions 216 me 359% 1063
abonnés et sur les 28 derniers jours il
ya eu plus de 2 millions de vues c'est
ouf
et vous avez été plus de 17000 585 à
vous abonner la durée de visionnage
explose c'est juste complètement dingue
99 1997
allez plus que 2 90 2 les désaveux pour
pourrir un peu la môme en eau
au 99 1980 on est chaud là on est chaud
on a perdu 1,99 1999 un héritage un
héritage l'ordinaire qui fera cent mille
yens il ya des cadeaux il ya des cadeaux
qu'on en parle après 99999 vue de
modérer la ferai ma faute a rencontré
une meuf ce serait nous amène à 99.99 tu
te fasses truc sans vie ouais
à droite
[Musique]
vous savez vous un truc vous aussi vous
avez vous une petite coup quand petit
verdot un petit truc savez vous que vous
êtes entré en seconde en trinquet c'est
bon allez on y va vous mettez la poste
sinon êtes sûr pour hiba al et il a la
sienne et merci ça fait du bien aux
l'abus d'alcool est dangereux pour la
santé
pour cent mille abonnés que marc de
champagne quand même donc voilà donc
tout ça pour vous dire que il ya un
boulot de dingue était fait alors barça
genre proche qui vais souvent fait et je
crois qu on a eu des incompréhensions
pas avec tout le monde avec quelques
personnes
et comme 16 personnes à bord de la route
je vous explique c'est à dire qu'on dit
souvent wes heureux tu réponds pas à tes
commentaires tu réponds pas que les
abonnés tendance ça couine tabouret je
vous montre qu'aujourd'hui presse de
tabouret de merde
donc je le change si vous connaissez un
bond de la preuve les tabourets vos
militants wen sur l om ce gros tu t'en
moques de thé abonnés tu ne réponds pas
aux commentaires
aucune n'a pu t'en fous complètement et
je vous assure que non pas du tout pas
du tout pas du tout pas du tout bien au
contraire
au contraire c'est même très heureux de
pouvoir être là avec vous si j'en suis
là c'est grâce à vous si je réponds pas
aux commentaires
c'est que en fin de compte j'ai
réellement pas tant c'est de ma faute et
je sais que c'est ma faute c'est des
choses que je l'amélioré
c'est à dire que je vous explique pour
sortir une vidéo jours ça me demande à
peu près on taffe aller entre 10 à 12
heures par jour de taf
alors je sais c'est à dire qu'il ya moi
je suis pour la famille georges besse le
soir jusqu'à 23h minuit passé une
journée à peu chargé me plains pas je
suis super heureux mais c'est juste pour
vous expliquer un petit peu le pourquoi
du comment
ce qui fait qu'au final lorsque j'ai
terminé ma journée très tard je gifle ou
sans clavier répondre tu as un
commandant et voilà un peu le pourquoi
du comment ce jeu c'est qu'aujourd'hui
j'ai beaucoup de mal à trouver du temps
pour répondre aux commentaires
mais je vais améliorer tout ça que je
vais essayer de faire et je vais
remercier de les tenir
c'est à dire répondre au commentaire
d'une vidéo dans la première journée de
vie de la vidéo après j'ai bien peur que
sur les jours suivants je répondais la
commande à la vidéo la presse puisse pas
répondre aux vidéos antérieur donc si
vous avez vraiment des questions à poser
sur un contenu je vous invite vraiment
une vision
le jour où il sort des watts directeur
et que si j'ai un peu plus de temps
j'essaye de répondre davantage mais
voilà c'est vraiment pas de la mauvaise
volonté c'est vraiment pas que je m'en
fous de mes abonnés c'est absolument pas
ça chez moi et j'ai passé cent mille
plusieurs tournées
[Musique]
g
c'est vrai mais ça na li tous merci les
gars happy town à 3 oui j'en ai un petit
choc la lumière à l'élève et aux allées
et son métier tout ça que je l'aimerais
été barman à l'évasion
cette année c'est le losc oui
bravo ça c'est cool tu as merci à vous
deux vous êtes abonné en 100 m
check check et maintenant on arrive au
point le plus intéressant parce que si
aujourd'hui j'en suis à cent mille
abonnés c'est pas grâce à moi il ya mon
taf mais c'est surtout grâce à vous
c'est parce que vous vous êtes là parce
que vous intéresser à ce que je fais
parce que ça vous plaît voilà moi je
l'espère sinon on va provost a donné du
coup pour vous remercier et j'ai décidé
de vous faire des cadeaux de faire des
cadeaux du coup ça fait plusieurs jours
que le jeu démarche des partenaires des
personnes avec qui je travaille pour
pouvoir vous remercier donc je lance
aujourd'hui par pour les cent mille
abonnés le grand concours le grand
concours monsieur greu des cent mille
abonnés avec plein de cadeaux à gagner
alors vous allez voir vous précipitez
pas écouter vous allez voir c'est cool
vous avez le lien en bas dans la
description pour pouvoir aller
participer qu'il ya plein de cadeaux y
en aura pas pour tout le monde
vous n'êtes plus de 100 mille tonnes les
cadeaux je vous dit qu'il voulait qui
vous les offre xiaomi xiaomi vous offre
une nuit twlight ça c'est tout premier
cadeau de la part de shiro me moi on
m'avait offert et du coup je le suis de
vous offrir
c'est une
me 23 condor merci condor également
merci chez oh oui merci condor condor
vous offre 1 m3 donc ça c'est plutôt
cool wiko vous offre un view deux plus
merci oui qu au pour vous autres 1ère
x17 neo
merci également aux peaux motorola vous
offre un g6 plait merci motorola rhino
shield vous offre un package solide
suite sont leurs coques plus objectifs
photos hd 4k plus macro alors ça c'est
pas pour tous les téléphones donc si
vous gagnez vérifie dans vous avez du
téléphone qui va bien c'est à dire de
l'iphone galaxy note 9 galaxy s 9 est 9
+ one + 6 probablement d'être loin
depuis six thés et le p 20 ce temps vous
avez pas de ses smartphones vous êtes
être des amis à qui offrir les savoirs
philips ou vous offre de yoplait plus un
live strip outdoor ça franchement c'est
aussi un vrai régal pour éclairer la
maison
cros cole vous offre un corps x3 au nord
vous offre un honneur 8x merci au nord
asus vous offre un zèle folle 5 kleitz
je suis très content de pouvoir lancer
ce concours aujourd'hui vous aviez vous
avez le lien en bas dans la description
vous cliquez vous allez voir un truc
tout con faut juste rentré votre ennemi
pour vous inscrire alors je vous rassure
votre email c'est moi qui le garde je ne
leur vend pas je ne vends pas des
fichiers vraiment vous pouvez être
assurés là dessus et vous allez voir
vous saurez immédiatement si vous avez
gagné oui ou non ces de l'instant
gagnant et ça va durer plusieurs jours
dit non j'ai dit j'entends de la vidéo a
tourné aujourd'hui je vais pas y arriver
les goûts santé tiennent sans kerrigan
anniversaire dans tes gosses en 1011
cent mille mètres des buts et surtout
santé à l'eau il a trinqué avec le au
vote du champagne
j'ai eu un paquet à 81 900 pts était
prévu sa plus longue était prévue le
jour ton anniversaire la maison du
couple et plus 100 mille abonnés alors
qu'elle commette un fils je vais le
mettre
ce jeu m'a tout de suite le monsieur
greu simple comment vous le trouvez pas
mais c'est ma femme qui pilotera pour
man u versé alors ils sont à vendre sur
la boutique monsieur ghosn
pas mal hein pour sandra alors toute
l'eau cent mille euros c'est le prix de
la journée
quand je te jure quant à des potes comme
ça peut pas besoin d'avoir des mines
holdings
voilà un peu pour cette vidéo un peu
particulière un peu à part la vidéo des
100000 la vidéo du bonheur la vidéo de
la joie bon voilà je vous montre ce joli
t-shirt un de célébration je vous
remercie
je vous embrasse tous et toutes un tel
mon pote abbott
vous êtes a marqué tôt aux commentaires
boyer de l'amour de l'amour mais aussi
vous envoie d'amour jeu très heureux 39
ans aujourd'hui dix ans d'amour et
passer les 100 mille abonnés je vois pas
quoi demander de mieux
je vous embrasse à bientôt l'acte vii
[Musique]
la guitare baroque